guten tag est bienvenu dans l'épisode 2
de notre lait c'est sur cela ce gars
donnent le dernier jardin voilà petit
remix by squeeze ses news souvenez-vous
tricot venez de péter les armures des
gens et il était tout affolé j'ai dû le
caresser comme ça comme je caresse loi
tous les matins avant de venir faire des
vidéos et ça l'a apaisé et s'est
redirigée vers cette cage avec le tout
bleu dedans il a sniffé donc je sais pas
s'ils vont retourner en arrière ou s'il
faut nous aussi fait des choses c'est
chelou je pense pas que nos amis qui ont
fait le je voulais qu'on steve des
choses en juin mais alors on va
descendre descends descends lâche
l'oreille l'âge de seconde son animal je
sais que tu as beaucoup d'affection pour
lui du coup risqué un truc à faire ici
ou pas du tout il a l'air vraiment
intrigué par ce truc c'est qu'il faut
que je trouve une clé ou alors je dis
n'importe quoi puis j'ai pu miroir c'est
vrai j'ai pu bien bons envoyés pour
remonter
il se dit c'est pas me labouraient faut
aller là-haut c'est ça faut aller là où
l'attenté soit mettre debout
excuse moi mais n'a alors je vais
retourner là au tricot à ce qu'on peut y
faire
je suis là je suis là je suis pas sur
toile montrent qu'à faire la revenir en
arrière en fait je suis pas sûr du tout
bon je crois que j'étais pas aller
là-haut dans le trou on va aller voir
j'ai besoin de toi mon gars allez bouge
pas ok je sais plus on était allé par là
ou pas je suis là je suis là ils l'ont
déjà
ok donc on peut pas monter par la
deuxième en tout cas faire assez
horrible d'être bloqués bonjour si le
chaos charrie si je suis toujours
bloqués dans cet endroit je sais pas ce
qu'il faut faire
il ya une chaîne là j'aurais que
j'atteigne la chaîne en fait tout
simplement mais comment je fais pour
atteindre la chaîne faudrait que jamais
un objet peut-être c'est ça donc là
tricot ne peut pas bien que sa tête qui
passe alors peut-être que deux en
montant sur sa tête ici à temps
vous n'êtes que d'ici en fait je vais
attendre un oui c'est cette faille faire
mon dieu je suis du coin c'est assez
jouissif monga pas c'est tellement
jouissif quand tu te descoings comme ça
donc là je me retrouve au dessus au bord
mais à quoi ça me sert en fait d'aller
là bas en fait ça va avancer à rien
[ __ ] ah mais si regardez
et comme ça j'ai pour atteindre la
chaîne tralala
tu sors ok pas totalement fait exprès
sur la fin parce qu'on tire attention ce
haute voix coach pas équilibre saute ça
marche toujours
allez on y va on monte on monte on monte
tricot du coup il est toujours bloqué en
bas waza pauv' tête
on attend la lumière on va trouver un
moyen de décoincer l'extérieur et je
pense qu'il va faire le tour il va se
démerder façon il est malin en tricot
c'est un gars malin c'est notre
meilleure amie pour rien et on arrive
ici et c'est de tout [ __ ] de beauté
allons dans l'herbe pour ont cette force
à gladiator ça
la scène où ils courent ces gamins
courent dans le dans les prés comme ça
petit moment de nostalgie
alors voirie vont nous on arrive en bas
voilà on va lui indiquer de sauter je
pense depuis ici allez viens tu viens
viens mon grand ont fait le tour
il arrive je suis sûr qu'il va sauter il
dandine du cul comme les chiens fait
tout drôle ça va ça va ça va tu montes
tu es bon tu montes
c'est bien mon grand parfait on n'est
pas bien là tricot qui sia qui skie à tu
regardes quoi il n'ya rien tu regarde
juste la tour toi tu me fais peur et je
te montent dessus peut-être ça veut dire
mon poids dessus je devais bien cousin a
jeté sous le tricot haye va sauter
d'assaut t je le sens elle reçoit il
s'accroche bien ce gamin on y retourne
fantastique
alors est-ce qu'on va je crois qu'on a
plusieurs chemins possibles ici soit on
va tout droit là bas soit on va ici à
mon avis va falloir aller ici mais dans
le doute on va commencer par aller là
bas rien une petite estrade là hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop
combien vital est très serein ce petit
et ça mène sa main totalement nulle part
et ben direction l'autre trouve fluide
permettre l'inspection
alors regardez il a déjà sa tête dedans
c'est ouf comme ce comportement on
dirait un vrai animal quoi l'ol fait
pareil mais certaines ont détruit
qu'elles restent coincés tu as des
courses et c'est exceptionnel faut que
je donne mon gars ou où tu mets ta tête
tu dis je ce match était ébloui goma au
micro c'est ça qui t'attire tu veux que
je bouge pas et je peux le tir et donc
moi je les tire
là-bas watry qu il al air de centre ii
qui fait là alors on tire on tire on
tire on va voir où ça nous mène
du coup il va se mettre dans un autre
trou et ça me permet d'accéder à quelque
chose c'est ça la met ta tête
vas-y vas-y mon grand voilà il est
vraiment mode d'al oula il a envie d'y
aller quoi ayo [ __ ] très copains je
pense qu'il devra y accéder par ailleurs
non way a regardé par la faire ça
pendant qu'il as la tête dedans et qu'il
a attiré as il faut qu'ils sortent en
fait c'est super bizarre elle sort de la
salle de la saulx
elle m'écoute plus du tout un vrai
animal il ya de la bouffe ça y est son
bal écouter ce que je dis peut-être de
voir le pousser en fait de l'intérieur
ok je pense qu'il faut assez bons il
s'est retiré à temps avant de remettre
la tête non attends non tricot c'est
infernal bien chanter qui veut manger
dans ton assiette alors qu'il a ses
croquettes
à la fac il m'a fait peur ce qu'on le
mois d'aout art à tête s'il te plaît se
caressent lève la tête ça veut dire lève
la tête
tikhonov après en vrai je suis pas sûr
que la solution c'est d'aller là-haut
non plus en fait
ah ok je pense a compris je pense avoir
compris pourquoi j'ai mis tant de temps
la différence entre 8,3 tous issus du
milieu il ya de l'air mais je vais
pouvoir m'agripper pour monter je pense
que iata oui c'est ça [ __ ]
mon dieu j'ai mis tellement de temps il
avait dix minutes que chercheur je suis
beaucoup moins haut que la terre la
voilà pour tous les aînés c'était du
coup qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir faire
exactement ici alors on a une on va
s'imbiber de potions jeu pas sûr que ce
soit une bonne idée là dedans ça a l'air
bien chaud en bas quand même bon bah
écoutez manière ya pas 36 choses à faire
on va tester
hop je suis en hauteur man ok allez je
peux la fermer pour que ils arrêtent de
péter un câble c'est bon ça c'est fermé
du coup il se détend le un peu le trou
du cul tricot ça permettait juste de
libérer un peu tricot pour ensuite
l'utiliser pour faire le vrai truc qu'on
doit faire
qui je pense est ailleurs un tricot non
c'est pas faut aller bah moi non plus
voilà à mon avis maintenant du coup faut
aller là ça c'est clairement pas là pour
rien il va juste mettre sa tête il ya
des herbes regarder on va pouvoir
atteindre peut-être une hauteur un truc
je m'éloigne je veux pas être otage
m'éloigne allait peut-être si je parle
carrément un endroit une voie plus il va
vraiment venir il va péter un câble
ouais et j'ai entendu un gros bruit
change pas où il est mais on l aime ce
tricot vite tu veux jusqu'à moi
autosport en même temps c'est trippant
le blème secte aurait dû faire ça avec
moi sur ton dos je pense maintenant je
pense qu'il faut qu'ils restent là haut
et je vais pouvoir monter dessus grâce à
queue ouais je pense que c'est ça n'en
reste en restant reste en restant l uta
que lé là oui c'est une grande cuve que
voici
tu va me permettre de monter dessus
reste l'amour est là où j'arrivais rajab
c'est assez instinctif en fait par
moments
des fois c'est un peu complexe mais des
fois ses formes souvent même si très
instinctif donc ça c'est agréable à
jouer
merci mon pote jeu pour accéder à
l'intérieur et te laisser seul
voilà allez on y va au à top aïe mais tu
n'as pas honte n'est pas je suis tricot
bon là on est clairement bloquer un
leclerc manger de voir se monter dessus
pas d'autre solution alors ok je suis
sur toi escape à un petit rebord un
petit truc à tout va sauter que ça fait
peur qu'autre chose intrigue aux médias
qui tient sur quoi là tu fais vraiment
le les ninjas ok bah écoute merci star
fout là que tu as pas sauter là là tu
vas pas sauter tu vas pas sauter puisque
rien donc je passe à gauche si tu va
sauter le qu il va sauter tu as de faire
le fou tricot on est bon je te fais pas
chier la être comme ça sur ton sur ton
forme bombée nous a mis bien ça te fait
du bien long c'était beau double regard
des luttes qu autant on dirait un vrai
[ __ ] de chat c'est vrai ça
teddy qui a peur de l'eau avait
peut-être peur de la profondeur mais
constitue une petite flaque requis
keith ya
[Musique]
il ya un deuxième tricot il avait au
niveau où il va direct on a trouvé tabac
on y va ensemble en grand allez je te
suis vas-y monte monte comme tu sais
faire là haut vas-y je pose à la nette
baisse d allaiter co maintenant on y va
alors on va aller là dedans j'ai compris
il faut aller à l'intérieur pour réussir
à aller tout temps il ya un de tricot je
comprends plus la même temps il
s'appelle tricot un tricot le tricot
quand tu tricote il ya deux aiguilles
tout et corrélations ouhlala profonde
c'est le gros vide on dirait que je peut
escalader ça ouais à mon avis ce qui
peut faire à l'hawaiien levier ya un
levier mon gars mais je leur dis non à
mon avis faut que je fasse by myself
comme on dit tu me fais peur quand tu
fais ça
utaka oui j'ai jamais autant aimé une
queue de ma vie franchement c'est trop
pratique mon gars hobbes et des pervers
c'est terrible ça il a très bien compris
que j'ai besoin d'aller là il me emmène
immédiatement il est adorable
on y va c'est parti tricot c'est la
folie alors je passe d'un autre côté je
te dis là ouais on peut monter mais ça
sert à rien j'ai compris je n'avais pas
vu il faut aller là par derrière ta faut
vraiment observé j'ai pas encore tout à
fait le réflexe de bienvenue observé au
qu'est ce que c'est que ça mais c'est à
manger tricot
ça tire ça ça y'a pas de soucis l'arrêt
du monde à ce que je fais maintenant
non je pense qu'il faut que je lance
pour l'attirer dans moi je veux attirer
l'autre côté avec un élu c'est ça la
strate je le mette la up claque et je
vais baisser le levier la porte s'ouvre
oh [ __ ] et voilà il a sauté pour la
bouffe à n'ont même pas pour la
curiosité ouaya de la bouffe si jamais
tu ris costume de maître bien tiens je
te l'envoie au plat à les bouffes voilà
il ya le pôle va monter aux anneaux
tricot au final on descend on n'est pas
bien là mais pas bon alors droite ou
gauche gauche on a un beau cul de sac et
droite on a ou la salle
je pense qu il faut que tu joues au chat
perché là ça veut dire monte sur mon dos
va tard c'est que ça veut dire ce cri
fais nous rêver je suis prêt
voilà peut-être qu'ils smic beaucoup
parce qu'il sent l'odeur de l'autre en
fait comme les animaux allez hop c'est
que je sais que tu dois c'était ça c'est
une vue sur un gros trou de balle alors
est-ce que le truc c'est qu'il a pas
besoin
je vais fils la bouffe qui cherche avant
en fait mais oui j'ai totalement jeu a
baissé ça qui sans et voilà en fait faut
y aller tricot l on descend on y va
c'est un peu haut c'est bon c'est bon
c'est mon petit garçon a des mots les
solides ya du manger ici oh c'est quoi y
est les harper tricot comment je peux
t'aider
comment je peux t'aider à temps faut que
je monte dessus sur moi je me faire tuer
en fait faut que je monte je suis
absolument tricot vas-y font surtout
attentes ricochet en danger habitué des
fonctions est défoncée il va me choper
d'achopper tricot vas-y de fontenay
allumettes et chapleau non pourquoi ils
veulent nous séparer
j'ai vraiment besoin de monter sur toi
ou et tricot c'est bien exterminent les
weppes les fonds s'était défoncés à je
te retire le plus rapide 1 il est blessé
je te le redis je te tiens tu me tiens
je te le dire ça va désolé tu en avais
un deuxième ça va ça va attends attends
calme toi comme toi calmes toi je te le
retire je te caresse on est bons tricot
comme à l'hôpital à pic
beaux contres à un temps du chrono new
dedans au touquet ou l'ena il est à
hauteur car like to in iz et haitink de
cannabis a dit long allez mange pas dit
ça traînait force mange le vas-y vas-y
scheckter envies plaisirs égale toi
c'est bien mon grand c'est bien mon
grand ça va tu as pris cher quand même
toit dans la faillite là allez on va
essayer de s'en sortir
ji paï elle a dit m deux trois coups ça
l'a fatigué
il faut que j'aie ce cas là tu ça allait
elle est là que la grosse que à merde si
c'est bon allez on continue
ça fait pas du recul on marche pas se
pratique c'est pour toi que j'ai ça ok
je comprends pas il faut qu'on monte en
fait que descendre c'est exprès c'est
pour nous stresser on veut dire [ __ ]
il ya un autre tricot et il est là haut
au tricot j'aime rire
gbla besoins des tricots eux
vas-y pas là bas c'est moi je cours à à
merde ça fait deux sacs
ok c'est bon il va se faire je te
soignes aurais je soignerai dvd montent
et démontent les défoncer à mais sont
souvent [ __ ] je peux pas l'aider c'est
horrible allez faut que je montre que je
m'en fous je monte j'étais trouvé une
arme un miroir un truc
en fait il est dans un endroit trop
petit pour pouvoir se défendre j'ai
l'impression c'est bon et je crois
qu'ils les années molly
je suis désolé mais je sais pas qui
c'est ces gens je sais pas ce qui te
voilà c'est dit veulent te tuer pour
faire un manteau 20 x l j'aime pas voir
tricot souffrir je suis sensible
par contre là ce que je vois c'est que
je suis tout seul il ya plus tricot la
sacr un peu non long espace avec une
porte bleue comme tout à l'heure tu
l'aimés à quoi elles servent
j'arrive à te voilà mon grand tu as des
lances planté où ça va aller je crois
qu'ils étaient allaités cette fois c'est
pas ce pas forcément mieux mais au passé
la superbe dans le couloir je ne l'avais
point de vue ah bah finalement nous
avons c'est vrai grand chose mais c'est
juste des sortes de balcons ok si je
fais le grand saut la ce la mort j'ai
envie de tenter
qui ne tente rien n'a rien moi non on
parie combien il va y avoir un
guet-apens
il apporte là bas il ya des soldats qui
vont sortir je pense que ça c'est le
guet-apens bien tricot mais voilà bon du
coup on a enfermé ici tous les deux en
amoureux
peut-être que l'autre tricot s'est fait
piéger la même manière et il a tué les
gardes
qu'est ce qu'on en pense de cette
théorie a été attirée par un truc qui
tue riad al hayya un levier comme en
août ça ça c'est l'énigme faut que je
passe de derrière la grille et pour
aider à la grille à mon avis je dois
pouvoir trouver un accès mois par un
petit trou un petit truc et je vais
faire le tour pour pour aider ben voilà
juste là tout simplement
il ya un mec est une [ __ ] un statut
juste là je vais tuer le viel va se
réveiller enfin je cours vers tricot je
suis désolé tricot c'est sûr elle va
sûrement sa vie à la le mec est donc pas
du tout quoi pascal le grand frère il a
l'habitude d'attraper les enfants comme
ça beaucoup des bateaux alors on y va
tico tico
ils ont dès lors ce décret mais qui
choisit de me remettre à toi j'espère
que tu vas gérer je veux pas te voir
mourir tricot voit la défonce les
députés ouais je te caresse tout cas la
sentence de quatre cents ans aimerait
bien trouver une courage nice nice ça va
ils étaient font cela boisclair pas tant
la bouffe les ou pire boufflers dans la
foulée de celle voilà comme ça très bien
y en a plus c'est bon ok alors j'ai
juste eu retirer les pépins
désolé on est bon allez bien par contre
ça se passe où je pense je dois monter à
l'échelle avant ayen salle garde là où
il se tient comme un boss tu sais le gac
attend jean relooking cas pas peur je
vais monter fille ouais c'est pour le
levier de l'autre côté c'est bon le
levier c'est le biais là il faut que tu
iras sais pas c'est une chaîne
ah ouais mais le peuple sait que je tire
ça va revenir ouais je pense que ce truc
là sans cesse lever avant et à mon avis
pour lever ce truc là il faut aller au
bout
hélas oui à notre garde c'est sûr
j'avais en moi diolot alors c'est toi le
boss du donjon c'est ça qui bloque
l'accès mais bien jusque-là tricot en
fait ok bon ben je suis safe être au duc
ok là n ont qu il va tenir le garde et
voilà et ben voilà ça n'a pas loupé on
est bien on est gay c'est bon il est
marié mort il est mort alors tricot est
ce que tu saurais prendre ton envol pour
l autre côté c'est une question que je
pose sincèrement je m'en tire toi que je
fais ça elle avait dû fait le saut il va
y aller là il adore faire ce coup là
[ __ ]
à allawi un levier pardon pardon il ya
un levier là bas vas-y viens viens mon
pote eh bien ça fait pas mal à penser
que je te suis allé plus loin comme ça
qu'on atteigne le levier là-haut à la
vision peut le faire mais bon moi mon
avis il faut aller là bas
là ils et ricoh va rien faire il a dit -
jfk j'en ai marre abord merci le chaos
chars mais ce n'est pas évident je
pensais qu'on pouvait atteindre le
levier en fait trop à quoi bon changer
pas trop encore la notion d auteurs
qu'on peut atteindre et d'autres qu'on
peut pas atteindre
olala c'est beau ici gidon focus calade
iia de la bouffe
je pense qu'en fait avant lui demander
de faire un effort
il faut lui donner à bouffer voilà quoi
sert la bouffe c'est la dernière fois je
savais pas trop si c'était pour lui
donner du pouvoir ou pas mais je pense
en fait que ouais c'est juste pour qu'il
obéisse
tu es sûr bas les couilles de toi en
vrai ah ça se lève 1 via de la bouffe ça
c'est la wilaya du monde voilà à la la
la et regarde le saut tu attends attends
au dg cricket en décembre j'ai eu très
peur pire que rater un train la sncf
raté un saut de tricot ne me prends pas
pour un imbécile tricot allez vas-y tu
vas aller tu m'as faut qu'on aille là
haut à gauche
là haut à gauche
ah je pensais qu'on pouvait accrocher à
temps mais je peux passer à travers ça
fait vingt minutes que j'essaye mon gars
de trouver quoi faire je peux juste
passé entre les barreaux le dit quand tu
vois une grille tu cherches pas si c'est
comme quand tu es en prison il ya une
gueule tu cherches pas sortir j'ai fait
beaucoup de prisons ses faux seins merde
[ __ ] bonbons soir avec ses débuts du
jeu on connaît pas encore toutes les
deux les mécaniques et je pense que de
toute manière tout au long du jeu en
voir découvrir des nouvelles
oh le coup oulala ya beaucoup de trucs
là ou là là il ya une caisse à déplacer
qui va nous permettre d'atteindre un
endroit à mon avis ou faut qu'on a ici
on a deux caisses américain j'ai même
pas eu de mandat fait tu fais quoi tu es
passé entre les barreaux a aussi été un
vrai fiasco a été comme ça que tu
arrives à le devenir comme ça je compris
que mangent les bars il s'y sent une
caisse à bata ça pétait la casbah 6,6
phase i papeete yalla vas-y assis va y
arriver en fait non mais tu viens d'en
casser il me dit pas que senna tu la
casse pas à a quasiment le montant
franchement ryan toi je sais toujours
pas quoi ça la bouffe un tel que je suis
con dès que vous l'aurez deviné alors
donné des ordres tout en maintenant l 1
contre les garçons pour donner des
ordres à donc maintenant je peux donner
des antilles je vais donner à ses looks
pour qui mme aubry
je caresse oc
ah ok je peux lui dire d'aller à un
endroit précis maintenant x et pour lui
dire aux pieds ok on sait pour lui dire
je pourrais dire quoi d'applaudir entrée
en lice pour sauter et caresser pour
pousser d'accord d'accord mais je peux
vraiment lui donner de lui dire où aller
lui dire quoi faire génial ça je veux
faire faire du cirque mon frère je faire
fortune on peut maintenant lui donner
des ordres j'ai fait deux trois tests on
peut lui dire au pied voilà il s'arrête
ça si on peut lui dire allez debout
l'air il se relève
on peut lui dire de sauter et on peut
lui indiquer un peu les endroits on veut
qu il aille comme ça pendant les doigts
je pense que si vous adorez les animaux
comme moi vous allez adorer ce jeu c'est
con mais on dirait tellement un vrai
animal je pense qu'ils ont volé mon chat
discrètement et développeurs pendant de
nombreuses années du coup eu le temps de
développement du jeu ils l'ont entouré
de capteurs et c'est de là qu'est née
tricot qui me rappelle thomas loi jumbo
pas trop jumbo il est moins gracieux il
s'est allongé ici c'est pas faire
d'autre et bien maintenant montrait un
épisode de mettre en ligne un épisode
tous les deux jours je pense même ça
tombe sur un jour où je mets déjà une
vidéo de base c'est pas grave vous aurez
deux vidéos à mater les faits je vous
conseille ça pour juste avant le dodo ça
apaise on est bien la revoir à la
vingtième massé avoir gardé portez vous
bien tout le monde